[MUSIC]
So welcome for joining us.
We're really excited to have you here.
I want to let everyone know that Renee is
now in her second week of fun employment,
as we like to call it.
So we just want to welcome you to that
life stage we know a lot about it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Im retired.
>> Temporarily.
>> Starting there, I'm just curious,
after 30 years at Intel,
what was it like the morning you woke up
and you knew, you were going to leave?
>> Yeah, that's a great question.
>> I don't know that it was one morning,
and
I apologize, I don't want to
have my back to these people.
I think it was a journey
of a couple of things.
I think everyone in the audience probably
knows that I was a candidate to be CEO and
I was not selected for
co-CEO which was the proposal we made,
but to become president.
So I think that was the first.
I actually, at the time, was thrilled.
And I still love the company so much.
I was so
excited to serve in that capacity.
But what I didn't realize three
years ago is that I really
did want to be the leader
of my own company.
And that became more clear to me through
the journey of the two and a half
years up to the point I decided to resign,
that I really wanted to be in charge.
And it turns out, you kind of get to this
point in your career where it's like, and
being in charge isn't so
much about being the boss.
It's more about setting the strategy and
creating the leadership environment
that you want, and making the decisions
around how you're going to handle things
that are more difficult in a certain way.
And so I kind of, I think it was kind
of in the background, but there were
a series of events that occurred where
I would've made different decisions.
And I realized at that point
that it as time for me to go.
Because I had a different point of
view about what was possible for
the company and
the path that I would take to get there.
And I think everybody knows I worked for
Andy forever and
that he's still my mentor and
he would say, if you ever get to the point
where you no longer agree with
the strategy, what are you doing?
And so I said, what am I doing?
>> [LAUGH]
>> And then I quit.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] And everyone says to me,
that was either the bravest thing that
anyone's ever done, or the stupidest.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We're still going to figure that
part out.
And you know what, I did my exit
interview last Monday morning.
And the head of human resources who's
worked for me for, I don't know,
18 years, had to do the exit.
And I told him in advance, six months ago,
I said, Matt, you're going to need to get
ready for this, this is going to be
very emotional for you, he's like,
we're going to talk about you.
I said, no we're not, because I'm pretty
sure I'm going to be okay in that meeting,
it's going to be you.
And it went exactly the way I thought.
They all came in, and they were all upset.
Are you still going to
take our phone calls?
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I'm like geez, okay,
I've gotta go because I'm retired now.
[LAUGH] Yeah, it was hard.
It's still hard, right?
I love Intel.
And I think Intel has
incredible possibilities,
but I would take a different journey.
>> So, let's talk about that.
You mentioned having a difference of
opinion on the strategy for intel.
In case the audience doesn't know,
a few instances in your career,
this came up prior.
So you had the early idea of Intel
housing outsource servers for
small businesses well before Amazon and
others were doing that.
The bust of 2001 sort of led them
to move away from that strategy.
Later on you tried to guide Intel
towards to be an early adopter of
the mobile strategy.
That again,
was an initiative that was not successful.
Talk to us about what it's
like to have that vision, and
some of the difficulties of shifting a
behemoth like Intel towards achieving it.
>> Yeah, I think the first,
they're kind of two different situations.
The first one was a kind of
an acknowledgement about how people would
want to consume technology over
the horizon, and as Andy says to me, well
you were absolutely 100% directionally
correct just a decade too soon.
[LAUGH] Which is the same as being wrong.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
that was his polite way
of saying you blew it.
Although he, by the way,
was the one who, he and Craig,
gave us way too much money for
that endeavor.
So that was a different situation.
That was a situation of
making what I would call,
managerial, or
more junior managerial mistakes.
It was my first senior management job.
I wrote a business plan that asked for
a lot of money.
$100 million is a lot of money.
They gave me 350 million, okay?
So when somebody gives you way
more money than you've asked for,
what's the first thing that you say?
You're in this graduate
school business at Stanford.
So let's hear it.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> No thank you!
No thank you,
I don't need that much money because
if you take it, they want a return.
So you don't want to take more
money than your business plan,
until you actually know or
hit the milestone at which you need it.
So when people want to over finance
you because they think you're a little
unicorn.
You say no thank you, I'll be back.
And after I prove to you
I've made this milestone.
Okay, that's your little tip of the day.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
I've of course said, my gosh $350 million,
that's a lot of money.
Think of all the things I could build.
Which I did.
And
then I got to lay all those people off.
So I think that was a learning
experience on two sides.
One, I didn't know enough to stick to my
plan and on the other side of it, I wasn't
a senior enough manager to convince the
then CEO that we should stick it out in
a smaller capacity, like downscale and
then stick it out through the down turn.
He just lost faith and decided to
sell it off, so that's Teradata.
But the second one is
a completely different situation.
This is a situation where I was
a senior manager at the time.
I was Executive Vice President
of the company.
And the CEO and I disagreed.
And he's the boss.
And I think that I did the right thing for
our shareholders and I think it was
the right strategy for the company, and
I think we'd be a very different company
if we had been able to pull it off.
And Brian and I tried, but it was four
years, or maybe five, Robert, right?
Robert's doing a case about it later.
There's a case about this.
And we lost too much momentum,
had 2 billion units in the field and was
shipping almost 2 billion a year now new.
And at certain point, in my industry,
in any industry, when you have a platform.
Once you get a network effect going,
it's just too late and
I think that was the case.
But that was a case where you had to
decide what you believed, and you had to
stand up for yourself at risk of political
risk and I think that's very dangerous.
And I think you have to
know what's at play.
And so I of course did what I always do.
I went and talked to people who've
advised me through my career.
You need mentors.
This mentor thing is real,
you really do need mentors and
I remember that Andy said to me,
this is one of those
situations where if it doesn't go well,
you might have to leave.
And I say yeah, and he said but
you should do what you believe,
if you think you're really right.
Okay, that's not helpful.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, now what?
But, I knew mobile was right and
I believed it.
I was on the board of Vodafone.
I could see the data.
I understood Paul's position.
We had a franchise that generates
cash that people dream about, and
you don't want to disrupt that and
pricing coming in below that is
a huge compression to your pricing.
But it's also was consistent with
the philosophy of the company which was
to always be a first mover and embracing
that which is going to disrupt you.
Right, so
it was a typical Christianson situation.
Seemed pretty strategically
straightforward and
we couldn't execute it.
And the why couldn't we execute it, why?
Because people do what they think
the CEO wants even if
they know it's wrong.
That's what I learned.
And that's a very dangerous phenomena
that people want to please and a lot
of large companies, although I see it in
start ups too, are very hierarchical.
And so they're like, hey,
this is what the boss wants.
And we hear you Renee and we know you're
right, and we want to do that and
we would do it, and we would start
with our hearts sworn in it.
And then when we have resource allocate,
it all comes down to money, right, or
resources, people, money.
Whenever resource allocation conflict,
it always goes the other way because
you know that's what the boss wants.
>> Yeah, yeah.
So you mentioned Andy and
you mentioned mentorship.
You started in till 28 years ago-
>> I did.
>> As a [LAUGH] technical-
>> But I was a lot younger.
>> [LAUGH] As a technical
assistant to Andy Grove,
who is sort of a Silicon Valley great.
>> That wasn't my first job, but it was
right at the seven year mark on my career.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> And so he was famous for
his confrontational nature,
he like to call it
constructive confrontation.
What did you learn while you were
working so closely with him and
how did that inform how you decided to
manage when you got to the president
role and throughout the rest
of your career with Intel.
>> Well, I think Andy had a couple
of pieces of advice that he
didn't always follow, but
that were actually very, very important.
I mean, we don't always,
all aren't self-consistent, but
one of them was to watch what people do,
not what they say.
And he used to say,
we'd be negotiating a partnership or
I'm an employer giving a presentation and
it say, yeah, you hear what they
saying but what are they really doing.
because whatever people are really doing
that's actually their strategy, right.
Not what they're saying.
So I have used that technique, I can't,
I mean probably almost every day,right?
I read what people are going to say
to me and then I kind of figure out
what have they actually been doing,
what's their real action?
If they are consistent then you have
one point of view and if they're not,
you don't.
The other one is clarity imperative.
And this is really important.
[LAUGH] Andy used to be ruthless and
one of my first, I love this story.
So I'm, all of, I don't know,
28 years old or something, and
I go into this meeting and
the guy comes in and he's got all this and
he's going to pitched for
a new networking business.
We were in and out of networking
probably four times at Intel.
And he begins pitching but he's actually
talking about something different.
[LAUGH] And he's like that's
not the topic of this meeting.
And he's like, well, yeah, no.
Yeah, [LAUGH] I've told this story
before in one of your classes and
he [LAUGH] goes, yeah, no,
that's not what we're here to discuss.
You're not being clear, you don't
have your act together and he said,
meeting is over, he got up and walked out.
It was a room full of people,
I'm like, that's kind of cool.
So but the clarity imperative
is really knowing what it
is that matters and being able
to write it down in five slides.
Like the five slide test
actually is hard and
I think that's one of the things
that he really forced.
He forced intellectual rigor and clarity
and that is something that has really been
defining of my leadership
style because I will tend
to find the thing that somebody's either
hiding or not saying and go after it.
And that is so Andy.
And I'll find it like in a millisecond,
it used to take me longer but now,
not so much.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] And I'll go as soon as I find
it, I know there's something there and
there's something they're not telling me.
And there's a reason
they're not telling you.
And whatever that is,
that's what's really going on.
>> Very interesting.
I hope you guys are writing this down.
>> It just happened.
I just told you the story
in the green room.
I just joined the board of Citi, and the
CFO came in and he was talking about all
these things, and I was like, wait, wait,
wait, wait, and he skipped over something.
In the normal course of managing
corporate finance of a company of scale,
Citi's about the same size as Intel.
You would ask the following basic things,
and so of course I just asked the question
he glossed over, I made him go back twice
and I knew there was something there.
>> [LAUGH] So okay, in terms of
talking about getting on boards and
thinking about how you analyze what's
there versus maybe what's being unsaid.
You have said that you wanted
to take on a CEO role somewhere?
>> Yeah.
>> What's your process for
deciding what exactly you're looking for?
>> That is a great question.
So my process isn't very good.
And my mentor explained to me that
I really, really sucked at this.
I made a list of the things I didn't
want to do, because [LAUGH] I decided
that that I could do so many things,
and I was interested in so many things.
And I really love my work at Vodafone,
for example, and
that's completely different from
running a semiconductor company.
And I find Citi very challenging and
Finn Tech and then what's going to happen,
I'm really interested in that.
So then I said, okay, but
what are the things that really
I don't want to ever do again.
The top of my list, my list right now
has three maybe four things on it.
First, no bad boards,
because at the end of the day,
when you're CEO, it's all about the board.
If you have a dysfunctional board,
and a board that isn't supportive, or
that has their own internal dynamic and
politics, life's too short for that.
No bad boards, no bad bosses,
well I actually don't really want a boss
ever again, [LAUGH] that's another topic.
And I want to do something that matters.
because there's lots of stuff that you can
do, there's lots of work in the world.
But at this point for me, I want to do
something that really contributes and
changes that matters.
There are something big changes in front
of us that I think I could go work on.
I have considered starting my own company.
I'm a scale operator,
that's what I am, I know that.
I've voluntarily advised start ups and
venture back,
and I could give them advice but
I'm definitely a scale operator.
So I've thought a lot
about starting my own, but
that's 24/7, 365,
which I've done for 28 years.
So I decided not to make
any of those decisions and
to take a short break which
has been one week long.
>> [LAUGH] And so far, what do you think?
>> I think I should get a job.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> I woke up this morning, and I thought,
thank God I have to go to Stanford today.
At least I have a reason to get dressed.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, I wake up at 5:30, and
I read my mail, which now only
takes me about 15 minutes, and
then I read all the news,
and now it's 6:15.
Then I work out, and
I have elementary school children.
Yeah, that's a whole another topic.
So I can drive them to school,
which I find fascinating.
And I also learned something important,
you can make any job stressful.
Okay, so apparently driving
the carpool can be very stressful.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Not for me, but for others.
[LAUGH] I'm like, seriously,
we're not solving here ladies,
let's just move it along.
[LAUGH]
>> So how is your family factoring into
your decision to
>> One of the reasons that I decided I
should take at least more than a week off
is My older son is looking at colleges so
we're doing the college tour thing.
And I'm getting him ready to go off to
college or apply to college next year.
So it's factoring in,
but my kids are worried.
They're like, mom seriously?
You're really high energy.
We [NOISE].
>> [LAUGH]
>> We don't want you around.
So I have way too many boards.
I have four boards right now.
Everyone's like, are you going to
be a professional director?
I'm like I want to say no I'm not, but
I think I am right now, but not forever,
because I do want to stay active.
And yeah, I'm just, most of the jobs
that are for CEOs, if you're not.
I'm an entrepreneur, but
I'm a large scale entrepreneur.
Are midcap.
And midcap might not work for
me because like having one product and
$600 billion of revenue is
like not my sweet spot, yeah.
I'm more kind of in the 70 to 100 range.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah because when I started looking at
the balance sheet of Citi, right?
Those numbers when they talk about
things we're talking about you know
multiple trillions dollars made in a day.
And you know the billion dollars
this way and that way and
that's the kind of a scale of Intel
it's kind of a scale of Vodafone phone.
It's kind of a scale of Oracle.
So that's kind of the mentality
that I operate in and
I think what happens Even if you shift
jobs a lot you should kind of develop
skills in certain areas and
you have a certain kind of capability.
>> Talking about scale on the level
that you're talking about scale, and
then talking about being an entrepreneur,
a lot of times those things
are very much at odds.
Or actually, I think I have a quote
from you right here that says,
we have a tolerance for risk taking.
We have a tolerance for
taking measured risks in betting.
It's not a tolerance for failure.
As an entrepreneur,
how do you think about that?
How do you sort of rectify and
what does that really mean?
>> Well,
I think at the scale that we take risks,
or I've taken risks, and I have failed.
And we do fail.
I mean, everybody who takes risks, fails.
Failures part of taking risks, right?
And you do have to have a tolerance for
failure,
so that's probably not
really accurate that.
I said that, I was wrong.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I mean you really have to be
able to fail.
You have to be measured though and I think
one of the things that I would say is that
in a large entity you can
take bigger risks, but
you have to ring fence.
What's the downside?
And so I do tend to understand like
how much are we going to really lose,
how long could we really sustain this.
You need to know those things because
large entities have very low tolerance for
loss, very low tolerance in general.
And so I think that's one of the things
that works against entrepreneurship.
It's very unusual that you
end up in Google, right?
Or even Oracle.
I mean, they're transforming this
company to be a cloud company,
at risk of a licensed business
that prints money, right?
So, but that will make them a bigger and
greater company, and
sustain them the next couple of decades,
so It's really one of these
things where you have to
understand what your tolerance is.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And large companies just don't have
that much tolerance.
And that's why they start stuff and
stop stuff and start stuff and stop.
So my biggest criticism of Intel is
that we always quit stuff right before
we could have made it, you know?
>> Yeah.
>> You look at a company like Mellanox,
a company you cannot even afford to buy.
Many of you probably don't know this.
It was a company that was ex Intel people
who took technology that Intel quit on.
Right?
>> Yeah.
>> How are they doing that now?
>> They're doing pretty good.
They're doing just fine thanks.
I mean there's tons of them.
I mean they're all they're
littered throughout tech.
>> Yeah.
>> Things that we gave up on.
>> Even data center.
>> Yeah.
What I hear a lot of in that
response is that you really knew
Intel you had a 28-year career there,
you had gone through different divisions.
You were sort of a subject
matter expert on Intel and
its tolerance for
risk-taking among many other things.
>> And its personality in the company.
>> Right.
And its personality and its culture.
Do you feel any insecurities about
stepping into a new role where
you won't have 28 years
with the company and
you won't be a subject matter
expert in that respect.
>> You know, I think I did for
a long time.
I don't now, but I did.
And I think that kept me from
ever leaving for a long time.
I think that's why people
stay at companies so long.
They love the work,
they know the situation well.
And all the things they don't like
they know what they're about, right?
I dont.
I don't have that fear anymore
because I think one of the things that
if you step back from the day to day,
either there's a lot of pattern
recognition in the behaviors of companies.
Different sizes and irrespective of the
content, a lot of the same challenges and
opportunities exist about
consolidations in the market,
about whatever's going
on in the competitive.
And you can actually apply, I mean working
at semiconductors has nothing to do with
banking, and I've been at the bank for the
last couple weeks being indoctrinated and
I realized, wow pattern recognition,
there are a lot of similarities.
When you have 200,000 employees working
in a whole bunch of geographies,
having a whole bunch of challenges,
you have a regulatory regime that
overlays the competitive environment,
you're like, wow, I get this.
I understand some of the, and
then actually it's been really exciting.
Like wow I could do something
completely different.
>> Yeah.
>> Although I think banking's actually
a tech business now.
>> [LAUGH]
Well.
You heard it here first.
>> No I mean everybody knows that right.
I mean the next billion people aren't
going to go open bank accounts.
>> Yeah.
>> It's a tech business.
And so
that makes it more appealing to you?
>> Yeah.
I love it.
I think it's fascinating.
I think that entire way
that economies work and
the movement of money and
the concept of crypto-currencies.
And I think fintech and
what's going to happen in
digital economies is going to be one
of the most interesting things that
are going to happen in the next ten years,
and that everything we've been doing.
One of the things that I realized,
I've been realizing is I've
been on this journey to what comes next is
that everything I've been working on for
the last 30 years is
actually infrastructure.
Like everyone had to have computers to
be able to do any of this other stuff.
We had to actually be able to
build computers at a cost that
allowed them to be pervasive.
And then all this,
I mean I can not begin to tell you,
unless you work in semiconductors how
complicated it is to build semiconductors.
It is so complex I mean it's mind
blowingly complex and dangerous.
And we build these huge
chemical buildings, and
they cost us 7 billion dollars, and
then we make these things that are so
small no one can even see them, and
they want to pay us 20 bucks for them.
That kind of sucks.
And at the end of the day, it really does.
It's a hard business.
It is building the framework for
everything that's built on top of it.
And everything that's built on top of
it now, computing is so powerful and so
pervasive.
And mobile is so
amazing, you can do like, I mean,
you do not need to go in a bank anymore.
And I think security and
identities, the identity thing,
I'm just super excited about that.
There's so much green space of what's
going to happen in identity management.
>> You mentioned wanting to
do something that matters.
>> Yeah.
One of our application questions that we
all have to answer when we come here is,
what matters most to us and why.
What matters to you, what falls into
the category of something that matters?
>> What matters to me is making
the world a safer place.
So the things that I find myself
working on, my free jobs,
my volunteer jobs [LAUGH] are for
the government and in cyber.
And I think the,
even at Citigroup I started working
on their anti-money laundering and
their cyber team.
I think the ability to know what's safe
and good is going to become even more and
more important to people in a world
that's less physical, right?
And I think that's a very
important frontier
because we have not made a lot of
not fundamental breakthroughs.
We're really good in detection and repair.
We're not really good in prevention,
and we're not really,
really good in identity management.
So, known good.
>> Yeah.
>> Right?
>> How do you think
about that in terms of,
you said those have been volunteer roles.
>> They have.
>> And you were appointed by
President Obama to help out with some of
the critical infrastructure work.
How do you make the decision between what
is going to be sort of a side service
project, and what's going to be one
of the main tenants of your career?
>> Well, I used to think
people would always say this,
they say this all the time.
You should follow your passion, the money
will fall and I was like that's just crap,
that doesn't really happened.
But it turns out it might be right,
I mean maybe I was wrong by that.
Because I keep drifting towards the same
kind of projects and even as I got on to
the board of Citi, that was the first
thing that I started to get involved in.
So, I think that that's my passion.
So I think it's going to'
become the primary, right?
Because I really think it's important
work and it's not getting done.
And there's a lot of small companies
doing bits and pieces of it.
When the problem's in security and
the problem I attempted to go after inside
of Intel, maybe that was a mistake and
should of done it outside of Intel, is
to actually consolidate into a platform.
There's no security platform.
You know how, you guys are mostly,
well not everybody's tuned into those.
But in the early days of computing right,
there's all these little weird things,
different applications and
then Microsoft, thank the Lord,
put it all together in a platform for us.
And as much as we'd like to bitch and
complain about them,
they changed the world.
The same way that Google did for
application development in the cloud,
right now Amazon's doing for services.
So those platforms are quite important,
because what they do is they move
the entire industry forward to a place
where a whole bunch of
innovation comes on top of it.
So that's what's happening in Amazon.
Amazon is the new great infrastructure,
kind of like Intel was in the 80s and 90s,
right, building the base infrastructure.
So I think that security,
that hasn't happened.
There's no galvanizing way to think about
how to put all this stuff together.
There's different point solutions.
So that's a piece of work
that needs to be done.
>> So while you were at Intel, you were
the head of Intel's diversity initiative.
The company pledged $300
million to recruiting and
retaining more minorities and
women within the company.
Was that something you drifted to or
was that something you sought out?
>> That is a great question.
The answer is I did not drift to it,
it reported to me and I embraced
it wholeheartedly at a point
in my career where I thought
that by me lending myself to it,
it would make it more viable.
Up until the point that I was
the president of the company,
I would say they had to beg
me to do women's initiatives.
I hate them.
I do, I think a bunch of women
talking to themselves about
how things are does nothing.
So I think one of the things
that was my big achievement,
was to get a whole bunch of men involved.
The he for she thing that's going on,
Intel has kind of the version of that.
Which is internal, the men involved in
having group dialogue about diversity.
And diversity is beyond women,
it's everyone
and we weren't doing a good job with that.
So I think we were able to do
a broader job in diversity.
I was able to lend my
position authority to
make it really get legs inside the company
and to some extent, outside the company.
And so, I was excited and
passionate about that.
I have a very strong sense of justice,
which is probably why I'm so
attracted to the defense of cyber crime,
right?
And I don't like that prior to this year,
we would publish data that would say that
women didn't make as much as men now.
That's been fixed, so
that's a fabulous accomplishment.
We just released the data last week.
But there's so much work to be done.
I'm happy that we're having a dialogue,
I'm happy to see that there's a dialogue
about it at Citi,
there's a dialog about it at Vodafone,
there's a dialogue about it everywhere,
that's great.
But it's a lot of work,
it's not done in one year.
>> So, I'll give you another quote from,
this time, your mentor Andy Grove.
He said, that kind of puts hair on
your chest, to do that and survive.
As a woman in software, in a company
that's a manufacturing company,
to do that, you have to have strength.
As a woman at Intel,
what was it that put hair on your chest?
>> Talk.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm trying to decide where to
go with that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
many think whoop,
showing up for work everyday.
When I started Intel,
which was a complete fluke.
I was working at a startup,
that Intel acquired.
And my family,
I grew up in Silicon Valley.
My dad worked at HP.
All my friend's parents worked at Intel.
I was like, yeah I am so
not working at that old man company.
It is not happening.
But then Intel bought us and then I was
like 22 years old and I had no money and
I wanted to get my master's.
So I'm like I'm going to have
to work there for a while.
And I went into it with no idea,
like I didn't apply to Intel and
want to work for Intel and
build semiconductors, and I had no idea
what the semiconductor industry was like.
So I was blissfully naive for
about ten years.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And then one day I got this review, and
you know how employees aren't supposed to
talk about their pay with other employees,
like that's against the rules at all
companies except they all do it, right?
So then I found out that I made
way less than all the guys,
and I'm like, wait a minute.
Woah, wait a minute.
So I went and asked my boss.
He was a legendary guy who works in this
valley and I said, why am I being paid
less, because I have the same amount of
experience and I've got a master's degree
and they don't, and I manage more people
and my projects are really successful?
And he's like, you probably make as
much money as you deserve to make.
Holy shit, so what did I do?
What do you do when that happens?
You call your mother.
So I called my mother and I said,
what do you think he's saying?
She says, I think he's saying
because you're a girl you
don't get to make as much.
And I said, that sounds wrong,
my mother's like, it is, do something.
You know my mother, my mother was the
first Santa Clara County sheriff, a woman.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I called her and
my gun toting sheriff mother.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And she says,
this is an outcry,
you should cry AFLCIO and I'm like, God.
[LAUGH] We're not unionized, Mom.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I go to HR and I say,
this is typical Renee I said, I think
there is something wrong with the data and
they are like, no there is,
we can't show you that data.
I'm like, but you have to.
You have to prove to me that I
make the same amount as the men.
And see this was the beginning of
a journey where I fought the system.
I fought the whole time,
and I didn't realize I fought
the whole time till the day I quit.
And I was sitting there, and
I was thinking to myself.
God I'm tired.
28 years.
because I fought
the system the whole time.
A system that was resurrected in an old
model that Bryan and I, and I think
Bryan's doing an outstanding job here
has revolutionized the culture of Intel.
I was working so hard on that.
And I give him a lot of credit for
that because that was really hard.
But my God, 28 years ago can you imagine?
And I was the only one.
So then I got into this habit.
This came out of this dumb review.
Every meeting for like a decade I'd write
in the corner how the men to one ratio.
So it'd be like 28 to one.
25 to one, so this went on for a really
long time and so I think what really made
me the person I am today is I fought for
equality from the day I got there.
And every single year, HR be like,
God, here she comes again.
I make them show me the data.
And if anyone inked ahead of me and
they didn't get as good of a review as me,
that was it.
That was it.
I laid down the law.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] I'm, and
I never got a promotion I did not ask for.
>> Like mother, like daughter?
>> Exactly.
>> Well, so
you mentioned Bryan in that comment, and
you guys were touted when you came on,
you as president, he as CEO,
management team as having
complementary skill sets.
But that was a first for
Intel, the dual team.
Can you talk?
>> Well, as the first to appoint
the dual team together but
it wasn't the first dual team.
>> Right, okay.
Appoint them.
>> Because, well, yeah, that's right.
>> Yeah.
>> Because well,
I want to correct that because Gordon and
Andy were a team for 17, 18 years.
Andy was president and CEO and
Gordon was the CEO and chairman.
And then Andy and
Craig were In the same set.
Paul did not have a partner for eight
years, there was an eight year gap, and
then they appointed both of us
at the same time which was.
>> So
how'd the board come to that decision, and
what are some of the advantages and
disadvantages of the co-leadership team.
>> Well, I'm a fan of co-leadership.
I still am, and even though I decided
I wanted to go lead on my own,
I'm a fan of co-leadership.
And I would have a co-leader.
I think it works really well at Oracle,
it's working very well there.
These jobs are too big for one person.
When you have 200 plus thousand people,
I mean by city has a co-leadership.
They have a CEO and they have a president.
You just need someone to be doing
some of the other stuff, right?
I mean, these are just big jobs.
So I'm a fan of that.
I think that when you have complementary
skills, that's fabulous, right, and I do.
I think the complexity between Brian and
I was that I have always been a strategist
and a market facing externally,
doing partnerships,
building business, running PNLs.
And Brian had been very
internally facing as COO, and
we really were in role reversal.
And I think that was one of
the more complex dynamics for
us because Brian needed to learn how to
develop and lead a corporate strategy.
And, that's an uncomfortable thing for
the CEO to have the president
be more adept at that which is
the primary job of the CEO.
I do think, to be fair to Brian,
he was extraordinarily,
gracious and letting me settle out
of the strategy and do things.
But a certain point in his tenure
he needs to run the company,
he is the CEO and
that's the decision the board made.
That was the point at which I said look,
this is your job Brian,
you're the one who's going to die or
live on the decisions.
If you want to go this direction go but
I don't agree.
But you get to decide.
You're CEO, so
I shouldn't work here anymore.
And as painful as that conversation
was it was the right one and
I think very adult, right?
because he needed to set the strategy.
It was time for him to do that and
I that was the complexity of
our particular situation.
Is that I was more skilled
to be a CEO in a second.
>> Is that a conversation you wish you
had had earlier in your partnership?
>> No, I actually think it went
exactly as it should of gone.
Because I think at the point we were at,
Intel had been led by an external person.
For the first time in history
the company would have hit sudden death.
Company was a huge inflection, there was a
lot of unrest about what direction to do,
we had to do a lot of changes that
aren't really apparent to you guys, but
we had to do a lot of cultural
changes around comp and
benefits and just a lot of stuff that
hadn't been dealt with for a while.
So, I think the right thing for
the company was stability.
I think the right thing for
the company was continuity.
And Brian's brought a lot of change and
he's on his path with
what he wants to do with IOT,
and I think that's fabulous.
So I think we have time now for questions.
We'll start with one question from Twitter
and then we'll head out to the audience.
So please.
>> Twitter.
>> Please be sure to raise your
hands if you have a question, and
they'll find you up and down the aisles.
>> So thank you both for
wonderful insights and
great banter which I always a fan of.
So the first question that comes
through is asking you know
you've been in Silicone Valley
your whole life.
If you could change one thing about it,
be its culture, attitude, interest,
whatever what would it be?
>> Wow.
First of all I should say I love it here.
I love the valley.
There's not a lot I would
change except I would
like it to be a little bit,
I'd like the diversity
discussion to be more serious,
in the sense that we got more traction.
It's one thing for big public companies to
do work on diversity, but the predominance
of the employment around this valley
is not big, huge companies anymore.
It's midcaps and entrepreneurial.
People like to move around a lot, and
I still think the diversity
issue plagues Silicone Valley.
I cannot tell you how much
time I spent advising or
spending time with really wonderful
companies still largely led and financed.
>> Hi there, thanks so
much for taking my question.
You mentioned briefly that you've never
received a promotion that you didn't
ask for.
Can you just elaborate on that a bit?
>> Well, so this is fascinating and
it turns out, has been through,
and I'm on a lot of
compensation committees, so
in addition to Intel, right, and
see this over and over again.
I am, as I admitted,
not the kind of big women's person.
But I'm going to sound like I am
with these comments, but anyway.
Women tend to not apply for jobs unless
they can hit every single criteria and
they think they're perfect at it.
So what happens is in interviews,
women will come in and
they will tell us that 10% of
the things that they are not good at so
therefore they're not good enough for
the job.
Their male counterparts will come in and
they'll be 10% qualified of the job and
they'll tell us all the reasons
we should hire them anyway.
And this happens in every company
that I'm involved with and
they're all big multinational companies.
And so,
the same thing happens with promotions.
I managed in a company of men,
I managed men.
For 28 years, and some women, thankfully
but not that many, and they always ask for
promotion.
Every year at their review, you're not
going to get promoted every year, but
every year I got asked for.
And I never,
women never ask for promotion.
Now I am an outlier,
I just behaved like my peers.
All I did was behave like all
the guys that I worked with, and
it worked out really great, but I don't
know what that is, it's a cultural thing.
We see it everywhere,
it's in all of the diversity data.
If you read anything online,
it'll tell you about this phenomena.
So, I think one of the things you just
have to get comfortable with is that
people ask to be promoted.
They do, and then asking to be
promoted you get an idea about
what their aspirations are, and you tell
them what they need to do to be promoted,
and then if they actually do it, you're
better off as a leader in a company,
because you got a whole bunch of output
and then you get to promote them.
You don't get that same dialog usually so,
I think that's the thing
that I always did.
I'm sure I was super annoying.
I'm really sure I was, but
>> Thank you Rene for taking my question.
I would like to thank
you because I work for
Soft Resolutions Group at
Intel under your leadership.
>> Thank you.
>> I came through the diversity
that I just loved Intel,
so thank you so much.
My question is how many more decades
would the Moore's law still be true,
how fast do you think it?
>> Moore's law is well alive and
well and as I no longer work at Intel,
I'm not in a position to comment
beyond that, but I will say that it
is absolutely fine, that is the least
of the worries of things that.
>> Not everyone know what Moore's law is.
>> So, Moore's law is the ability
to create more performance
every couple of years more in a,
in a smaller transistor package and, and
or in a denser lithography, so
people talk about going 28 nanometers
to 10 nanometers or this or that,
it's very technical and exciting but the
fact is what it's done is it's allowed us
to sequence the human genome
in a few days versus a year.
And it's allowed us to
find unique treatments for
cancer at the Knight Cancer Institute
in Oregon.
As a result of being able
to build basically what it,
ten years ago would have been a room full
of super computers on a single chip and
that's the benefit of Moore's Law and
it's what fuels the entire you know
kind of digital economy including
self driving cars which require
massive amounts of compute power and
some of the bigger breakthroughs, I mean
even in cyber and personal identity and
there's a lot about algorithmic profiling,
so a lot of that requires just tremendous
amount to compute that we
didn't have available to us and
the Moore's Law has delivered that to us
in the last decade and will continue.
And that's why I say Intel has been a
fundamental infrastructure company, right?
because what they're doing is building
kind of the blocks upon which
Tesla will make a self-driving car,
or Google, or whomever.
>> Hello Rene,
as a former Intel employee working at LTD.
Thanks for-
>> Look at all these adult people.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah, all these people.
My question will be but
culture I see there in
Oregon the Logic Technology
Development Department for
a few years and
I found this hardware culture.
You know about chip manufacturing
we value creativity but
at same time we value more or
at least equally disciplined in execution.
Do you find that culture is somehow,
separated from this
more of a software culture like Google,
Facebook, Uber,
we totally evaluate person our
individual individual creativity.
Do you find that art is part
of Intel's current situation?
>> So, I don't think that any company that
gets to the scale of Google doesn't value
discipline in execution.
I think, at a certain point in
the life cycle of any company,
you get to the point where it doesn't
matter what you're doing, discipline and
execution is critical to the results.
And so, I think Intel is not unique,
I mean if you were building
car batteries, you'd be in the same
situation as semiconductors, right?
Very similar technology,
and that discipline and
execution comes from health and safety.
I find a very similar culture
discipline execution over content
excitement about new innovation,
I'd say Vodafone.
Because health and safety kind of
overrules sometimes innovation.
So you get excited about something but
it might inject some kind of risk in to
the health and safety, so when you build
things that people die building, right?
Which when you are putting
up a mobile tower,
people fall off them unfortunately or
they electrocute themselves.
So when you're in that kind of a business,
health and safety tends to
put a process regime or if you're in
a highly regulated business like the bank.
It puts a process regime over innovation
and I think that's a difficulty and
I think as a leader you have to
actually create a avenue for
innovation, that's why you see so many
big companies creating these innovations.
And you kind of wonder like if innovation
on this side doesn't really help, so
it's complicated.
You have to be able to have a process
where the innovation occurs and
you pull it back in, right?,
because this companies you get to
certain point and you just have process.
It's unfortunate, that is part of scale.
>> Hi, Rene.
Thanks for joining us.
You spoke about the importance of
having good mentors in your career.
For many of us, we'll be going out to
the real world, again, and then hopefully-
>> I'll be with you.
[LAUGH]
>> Yes, so I'd like to hear from you,
best practices on finding
those good mentors and
setting the stage such that
they want to invest in you.
>> I think a mentorship
is a two-way street.
So, I think finding a great mentor
isn't so much about finding the person,
it's also what can you add
to that person as well.
And so, for a great mentor,
or I'll give you an example.
One of the people that is
in my Little Mentor circle
is this wonderful guy who works at Google,
but he is bidirectional mentorship right?
Like he's like you're I am
like LinkedIn seriously?
Like I have a LinkedIn site.
He's like your LinkedIn
sucks I'm redoing it.
So I mean so it's like bidirectional, I'm
coaching him about you know from a career
evolution perspective and
he's moving into management.
He's never been a big manager,
that kind of thing.
So I think it has to be bidirectional,
so you have to find someone that
you not only can advise you, but
that you can actually help them either by
bringing them forward in technology or
your interests or whatever.
When they're not bi directional,
they're a bummer and it's really hard.
Like the person never wants
to get time with you,
you'll find they're like busy always and
it's like a burden, right?
Like they want to say yes to you but
it's like what are they getting out of it,
kind of thing.
So also, if you're an entrepreneur, a lot
of people who may mentor you, sometimes
would invest with you and then it get very
involve in helping you be successful.
>> Well I'm going to
take the last question.
>> We're done.
>> And it has to do with your MBA.
Sheryl Sandberg recently
put out an article
saying that MBAs are not really
needed in the tech industry.
I promise we will not take offense,
but do you agree?
>> No.
>> Okay, tell us why?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, not because I have one I mean, or
that I love to go to the MBA
program here that I beg just for
them to put the program together for
Intel people or that.
I think, that education in general and
I think this undergraduate and
graduate Teaches you not only
frameworks but tools to think.
Right?
And I think the MBA gives
you an opportunity for
having had some experience in the world,
right?
And being out there, to then come back and
get frameworks and, I talk
a lot about pattern recognition, because
leadership is about pattern recognition.
It's about seeing multiple
patterns occurring,
understanding what that
competitive move might be, or
recognizing that you've seen this
before and what happened the last time.
And only through, I think,
you know, understanding the frameworks
of competitive strategy,
you know, economics, those kinds
of things, you need to know that.
And by the way, CEOs should be able
to read a freaking balance sheet and
an income statement and
know the difference.
And if they can't, that's a problem.
Really it is.
And there are those that the first time
they ever have to deal with corporate
finances when they become the CEO,
and you're like, really?
because now it's complicated,
because the world is flat.
And you have to deal with FX, and
you have to deal with hedging.
And you might be like,
what are you talking about Renee?
I'm going to run like a 100 million dollar
company, or a 10 million dollar company.
Yeah, good luck with that.
I mean, the economy, you're going to
sell to people all over the world.
Guess what?
You're going to have to deal
with tax and trade.
because you have to deal with the tax
issues when you sell in all these places.
An online tax, that's super complicated.
How about safe harbor?
So this is the stuff you learn
when you're in an MBA program.
You learn about the kind of
environment of doing business and
then you have contacts and
even if you don't know something,
you know, I should probably call
a lawyer about that, you know, right?
Or how to set up an entity
in a foreign place.
So, I don't agree with that.
I think we need, we have a whole
generation right now of super smart people
who are at 10 year mark in their career,
10 to 12 year mark in their career,
who want to be leaders, who have
absolutely no skills to be leaders.
Zip!
They should all come in the MBA program,
because they don't know anything.
They all grow up in unicorns,
and they make tons of money, and
they are like,
well I've done these like 5,000 projects.
And you're like, that's great, but
you know nothing about all this other
stuff because, see, the problem is,
once you get out of running a project or
being in engineering or being in sales or
being in marketing, you have to actually
then just do the boring stuff,
which is running the corporation.
And that stuff is like a whole different
level of stuff, it's not that other stuff.
It's the, gee, I wish people
wouldn't sue me for anti-trust.
That really sucks.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well it'd be good if you actually knew
what anti-trust law was, right?
So [LAUGH] and I taught it,
just at another business school,
where some students didn't understand that
some of the things they were proposing
were against the law.
And then you learn that, right?
You're in a business school class and
they say,
that's great, except that there's
an anti-trust law against that, right?
You can't combine with those people.
So, Cheryl and I,
I guess we'll have to disagree on that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> If everyone would join me in thanking
Renee James.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you.
>> Thanks.
[MUSIC]